Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Vous connaissez tous le célèbre
pharaon Toutankhamon.
Mais ce que vous ne savez peut-être pas,
c'est que peu après la découverte
de son tombeau, en 1922,
il y a pile un siècle,
une terrible malédiction se serait abattue
sur tous ceux
qui ont fouillé sa sépulture.
Avec Thibault,
de la chaîne Histoire Appliquée,
nous allons faire toute la lumière
sur cette énigme,
l'une des plus fascinantes du XXᵉ siècle.
Le 4 novembre 1922,
sous le soleil brûlant d'Égypte,
un jeune porteur d'eau
découvre une marche dans le sable
qui semble s'enfoncer dans le sol.
Il est loin d'imaginer qu'elle va mener
un groupe d'archéologues britanniques
vers le tombeau de Toutankhamon.
L'une des découvertes archéologiques
les plus célèbres de tous les temps.
Mais qui était Toutankhamon ?
Né vers 1345 avant notre ère,
il est le fils d'Akhenaton,
l'un des plus célèbres
pharaons de la civilisation égyptienne,
mais aussi l'un des plus controversés.
Grand réformateur, il s'est mis à dos
les responsables religieux de son époque
et a laissé un bilan économique
et politique absolument désastreux.
Son fils,
le jeune Toutakhamon, n'a que 9 ans
lorsqu'il monte sur le trône
après la mort de son père.
Probablement entouré de bons conseillers,
il abandonne
certaines réformes de son père
et tente de revenir à des approches
plus traditionnelles du pouvoir.
Mais en dehors de cela, on sait assez
peu de choses de son action politique,
car il est mort
prématurément à l'âge de 18 ou 19 ans.
Les écrits de l'époque ne précisent pas
les causes de sa mort.
Une hypothèse a longtemps prévalu
celle de l'assassinat,
mais elle est définitivement abandonnée
en 2005.
On a aussi avancé
la thèse d'une mort accidentelle.
Le mauvais état de son squelette suggère
qu'il aurait pu succomber
à un accident de char,
une charge d'hippopotame.
Mais là encore, rien n'est moins sûr,
car ses blessures semblent avoir été
faites après sa mort
ou pendant la manipulation de la momie.
Pour l'heure, l'hypothèse de la maladie
reste la plus plausible.
On sait que Toutankhamon était
de constitution fragile,
une fracture à la jambe
a pu s'infecter et provoquer son décès
dans d'affreuses souffrances.
Conséquence inattendue, les Égyptiens
n'ont pas eu le temps de lui édifier
une tombe monumentale.
Toutankhamon est enterré dans un tombeau
très simple et très discret.
C'est ce qui explique sans doute
qu'il ait échappé
au regard des pilleurs de tombes
durant des millénaires
et qu'il ait bien failli échapper aussi
au regard des archéologues du XXᵉ siècle.
En effet, sans la ténacité
d'un archéologue britannique nommé
Howard Carter, nous serions peut-être passés à côté
d'une découverte fabuleuse.
L'histoire de cette découverte
débute à l'aube des années 1910,
dans la vallée des Rois.
Nichée en plein désert égyptien,
cette zone ensablée
abrite de nombreuses tombes.
Elle est donc l'objet
de toutes les convoitises.
Depuis dix ans,
On y a découvert une trentaine de tombeaux plus ou moins intéressants.
Lord Carnarvon, un aristocrate
anglais passionné d'égyptologie,
rachète les droits de fouille en 1915.
À ce moment là,
la plupart des archéologues
pensent que la vallée des Rois n'a plus aucun secret à livrer.
Seul un homme est persuadé du contraire,
c'est l'égyptologue britannique
Howard Carter.
En 1917, il convainc Carnarvon
de continuer à financer les fouilles.
Mais il a beau chercher, lui non plus
ne trouve rien.
Jusqu'à l'automne 1922
ou quelque chose d'incroyable se produit.
Il s'agit de la découverte, par hasard,
d'une marche en pierre
par le jeune porteur d'eau
dont je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure.
L'archéologue comprend qu'elle mène
probablement vers un tombeau bien caché.
Il décide alors d'en dégager l'accès.
Comme beaucoup d'autres,
cette tombe a probablement été vidée de son contenu.
Carter ne se fait donc aucune illusion
sur ce qu'il va trouver à l'intérieur.
Rien ou presque.
Mais il n'abandonne pas.
Il tombe finalement sur une porte
dont les sceaux sont restés intacts.
L'égyptologue comprend
alors qu'il est devant
le tombeau de Toutankhamon.
Il n'en revient pas.
Enfin, le 26 novembre 1922,
il réussit à introduire une bougie
dans la tombe
par une brèche ouverte
dans une deuxième porte encore scellée.
Il parvient alors à apercevoir
ce qui se cache à l'intérieur
de l'antichambre
et ce qu'il y voit le laisse sans voix
durant de longues secondes.
A l'extérieur, Carnarvon s'impatiente.
Howard, que voyez-vous ?
En réponse, l'égyptologue lui lance
alors cette réplique
qui est entrée dans l'histoire.
“Je vois des choses merveilleuses”.
Il vient de découvrir
le trésor de Toutankhamon.
En faire la liste détaillée des merveilles
qu'il contient pourrait faire l'objet
d'une vidéo entière tant
ce trésor est gigantesque.
Carter écrira plus tard
“c'était un vrai musée,
une pièce meublée
des objets les plus divers,
les uns familiers, d'autres
que l'on n'avait jamais vus,
entassés les uns sur les autres
dans une profusion infinie”.
Il lui faudra environ 10 ans,
avec son équipe,
pour en dresser l'inventaire complet.
On va quand même vous en donner un aperçu.
En tout, on recense
près de 5400 objets
dans le tombeau du jeune pharaon.
Ça va du matériel d'écriture, aux armes,
en passant par des meubles, des statues,
des bijoux, des pierres précieuses,
des objets de la vie courante
et pas moins de six chars.
On y découvre également un trône incrusté
d'or et 130 cannes de marche.
Les cannes, c'est
un symbole bien connu des pharaons.
Mais leur nombre, particulièrement élevé
ici, pourrait accréditer l'hypothèse
d'un jeune homme
qui avait de grandes difficultés
à marcher.
Les pièces les plus emblématiques de
ce trésor,
ce sont bien entendu
les trois sarcophages en forme de momie
qui abritent la dépouille de Toutankhamon,
ainsi que son fameux masque funéraire
recouvert de plaques d'or.
Des plaques, pas des feuilles.
Il donne une idée du talent
des artisans de l'époque.
Alors évidemment, cette incroyable
découverte stupéfie le monde entier.
Mais très vite, l'histoire
va prendre une drôle de tournure.
Certains vont affirmer, preuves à l'appui,
que le tombeau de Toutankhamon est maudit.
En 1923, six semaines après la découverte,
Lord Carnarvon meurt brusquement
d'une infection généralisée.
Son décès intrigue certains journalistes,
qui échafaudent
alors une incroyable hypothèse.
Toutankhamon aurait jeté un sort
à ceux qui ont osé
troubler son repos éternel.
Pour preuve,
il publie le texte d'une mise en garde
soit disant
inscrite à l'entrée du tombeau.
“La mort vient ailée
à quiconque pénètre dans la tombe
d'un pharaon”.
Nous sommes dans une époque
où l'on se passionne
pour le spiritisme
et les sciences occultes.
Beaucoup de gens croient dur
comme fer que les momies ont des pouvoirs magiques.
Cette malédiction est donc prise
très au sérieux.
D'autant qu'au mois de mai suivant,
on apprend le décès du professeur Lafleur,
un égyptologue canadien,
puis la mort du colonel Aubrey Herbert,
le propre frère de Carnarvon.
Entre 1923 et 1930,
on recense la mort suspecte
de 15 à 30 personnes
ayant eu un lien direct
ou indirect avec la découverte de la momie de Toutankhamon.
Quelques scientifiques échafaudent alors des théories
sur les causes de ces décès.
Les torches du tombeau
auraient été imprégnées d'arsenic.
L'huile d'amande
douce utilisée pour embaumer la momie
se serait transformée en cyanure.
Bref, ce macabre bilan
alimente toutes les conversations
dans la rue, dans les salons, partout.
On va jusqu'à consulter des experts
autoproclamés comme Conan Doyle,
le créateur de Sherlock Holmes, afin
qu'ils donnent leur avis sur la question.
Mais cette affaire de malédiction
est loin de convaincre tout le monde.
Quelques journalistes un peu sérieux décident de mener l'enquête
et ils n'ont aucune difficulté à démontrer
que cette histoire ne tient
absolument pas debout.
À commencer par la mort de Lord Carnarvon.
Elle n'a rien de suspect.
De santé fragile, l'aristocrate a succombé à une septicémie
provoquée par une simple piqûre
d'insecte.
En outre,
on découvre que la plupart des victimes
n'étaient même pas présentes
lors de la découverte du tombeau.
A contrario,
d'autres personnes présentes sur les lieux
mourront bien plus tard.
Carter rend l'âme 17 ans
après la découverte en 1939,
et la propre fille du lord,
présente elle aussi, disparaît
en 1980 à l'âge de 79 ans.
Si on ajoute
que la moyenne d'âge des défunts
était d'environ 52 ans,
ce qui correspond à peu près
à l'espérance de vie dans les années 20.
Le doute n'est plus permis.
La thèse de la malédiction est
une pure mascarade.
Ah, j'allais oublier la cerise sur le gâteau.
Vous vous souvenez de la fameuse
inscription à l'entrée de la tombe ?
La mort vient ailée
à quiconque pénètre dans la tombe
d'un pharaon, tout ça.
Eh bien, en réalité,
on apprendra qu'elle n'a jamais existé.
C'est une pure invention des journalistes.
Ils ont monté cette histoire
de toutes pièces à l'origine
pour se venger de Carter et Carnarvon,
qui avaient donné l'exclusivité
au Times de Londres
pour la couverture médiatique
de la fouille du tombeau.
Privés d'information, ils ont trouvé un bon moyen
d'alimenter leurs colonnes à bon compte.
Par la suite, la question de la vengeance
ne se pose plus du tout.
Mais l'histoire était si bonne
qu'ils en ont fait un feuilleton
qui a évolué de semaine en semaine
pour le plus grand bonheur des lecteurs.
On l'a bien compris,
la malédiction de Toutankhamon
est une pure invention.
Mais ce qui est cocasse,
c'est que cette malédiction
va tout de même faire beaucoup d'heureux.
Avez-vous déjà entendu parler
de la bénédiction du pharaon ?
Il s'agit d'une expression
utilisée par l'égyptologue français
Marc Gabolde,
l'un des plus grands spécialistes
contemporains de l'Égypte antique.
Il affirme que la peur
d'une malédiction à cette époque
a poussé de nombreux propriétaires
d'œuvres égyptiennes à s'en séparer.
Ces gens étaient persuadés que ces objets
allaient leur porter malheur.
Résultat les musées ont pu récupérer
à peu de frais énormément
de pièces historiques de valeur.
On les trouve encore aujourd'hui
dans leurs collections.
Et contrairement
à la malédiction du pharaon,
cette bénédiction, elle est bien réelle.
Aujourd'hui encore, les expositions
consacrées aux trésors de Toutankhamon
attirent des centaines
de milliers de visiteurs.
C'est là toute l'ironie de l'histoire.
Toutankhamon a eu un règne
particulièrement court et insignifiant.
Pourtant, il est devenu,
grâce à l'archéologie et au phénomène de société de l'égyptomanie,
l'un des pharaons
les plus célèbres de l'Histoire.
Reste que l'Égypte et sa civilisation
antique passionnent encore
et que les bonnes histoires de pharaons maudits
ont de beaux jours devant elle.
Merci Thibaut pour cette histoire
épicurieuse.
Et un grand merci aussi à Toutankhamon
pour les merveilles qu'il nous a laissé.
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo,
vous connaissez la consigne,
vous laissez un pouce bleu
et vous vous abonnez,
si ce n'est pas déjà fait.
Enfin, si vous avez des idées de sujet,
ne vous gênez surtout pas.
Proposez-les, elles seront étudiées
minutieusement.
Allez, à très bientôt.
Chers Épicurieuses et Épicurieux.